courtney will tell you that she's one of
the best public peers in town khloe
kardashian reveals her sister courtney's
unexpected hidden talent drum roll
please
public urination isn't that crazy coco
appears on thursday's episode of the
ellen degeneres show and opens up about
her sister's um
skills and yeah she has video evidence
to back it up courtney will tell you
that she's one of the best public peers
in town um that's something to be proud
of no but she owns it with pride so i'm
you know be careful
she might have peed somewhere here who
knows what are sisters for if not to
embarrass you on national television you
know i'm not here to play games and we
can expect to see a whole lot more of
the sister shenanigans on our tv soon
which i'm so excited about the good
american founder told ellen that the
family's new hulu series is dropping in
early 2022. yeah i think in a few months
either end of january uh early february
fast really fast so that's the beauty of
hulu we're streaming and we get to have
a much quicker turnaround than
previously and we're really excited
they're here now in the back shooting
with us and we're so happy to be you
know up and rolling again and based on
this tick tock posted by travis barker's
son landon cameras were present shortly
after the blink 182 drummer popped the
question to court
so there's that to look forward to and
we can only hope there will be lots of
kardashian jenner kid cuteness too oh my
goodness okay and what is this lemonade
three dollars and bracelets 10 to 20.
yeah but they're handmade by penelope
you guys made this and north speaking of
the kiddos chloe revealed what her
three-year-old daughter true will be
dressing up as for halloween
true's gonna be moana and she wants me
to be pua the pig
[Music]
so is chloe gonna do it it's a little
shady of her but that's okay i will be
pua for true you're a good mother i will
be pula for true